good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight not many people are saying it
out loud on the right but the fact is
that President Trump could well lose
this election in fact unless fundamental
facts change soon it could be tough for
him to be reelected the President does
lose that would mean that just a few
months from now Joe Biden would become
the president the United States
government would fall under the control
of the radicals who control Joe Biden
and they will remake the country now
we're fully aware that virtually nobody
watching this show tonight wants to hear
that
but it's true and key people around the
president know that it's true they've
seen the numbers they're concerned at
some point in the future historians will
marvel at the fact that the president
lost ground during a pandemic and then
during mass riots both crises should
have highlighted his strengths they were
naturals for him alone among national
leaders Donald Trump warned Americans
for decades about China and the perils
of globalization everything about the
Wuhan coronavirus proved Donald Trump
right China really is our main global
adversary the Chinese government really
does want to take over the world
meanwhile the fact that we sent our
manufacturing base abroad really has
weakened us badly the most powerful
nation on earth no longer makes
antibiotics maybe we're not as powerful
as we think all of that is very obvious
now after the pandemic but Donald Trump
called it you'd think voters would
reward him for that
you think the riots would have increased
their support for him an awful lot of
people voted for Donald Trump precisely
to avoid a moment like the one we're now
in none of this arrived suddenly we saw
it coming social cohesion in America has
been eroding for decades people sensed
that it made them nervous
it should make them nervous Donald Trump
seemed like insurance against the
consequences of that the core appeal of
Trump was if things ever started to fall
apart he would defend you yes he was
loud and crude most bodyguards are only
a man like Donald Trump was tough enough
to fight the creeping authoritarianism
of the education cartel in corporate
America if Trump got elected you could
say what you really believe the basic
promise of America could be restored you
could live with dignity
under Donald Trump you wouldn't be
forced to mouth the lyrics to some
repulsive little orthodoxy you hate you
could declare out loud that all lives
matter because all lives do matter God
made us all and if you can't say that
what's the point of living here Donald
Trump never quite articulated any of
this in a precise way he's not an
intellectual or an ideologue but it was
obvious he felt it strongly
Trump's gut level instincts were on the
side of order and tradition and
stability and they still are and yet
when widespread looting and disorder
arrived the president did not act as
decisively as many had hoped he said
little he did last some voters felt
undefended some turned against him why
did this happen well there are many
reasons Trump was exhausted for one
thing after three years of defending
himself against Russia gate the most
elaborate and effective hoax in American
history and his staff did not very much
to help some of them were actively
disloyal most were just confused they
definitely were not prepared for Chinese
viruses or burning cities but the
administration's main problems were
conceptual few seemed to understand what
was really happening their first mistake
was forgetting the primary rule of
Washington in an election year
everything that happens is about the
election there are no exceptions to that
rule
Washington is a political city it's run
by politicians if the Chinese Navy
sailed up the Potomac in the fall of an
election year the first thing most
people in DC would wonder is how is that
going to affect turnout that's who they
are it's how they think so only the
naive were surprised when Democratic
governors immediately use the
coronavirus quarantines to punish people
who didn't vote for them Christian
churches and small businesses were
locked down weed shops an abortion
clinic stayed open most Trump voters
seemed not to notice they accepted the
restrictions without question this was a
health crisis and they wanted to do the
right thing
so they obeyed they cowered in their
homes and that's exactly where
Democratic leaders wanted them cut off
from one another
atomized and alone the few conservatives
who tried to organize resistance to the
lockdowns were indicted or threatened
with arrest
none of this had anything to do with
public health of course it was electoral
politics
especially brutal form of it Republican
leaders meanwhile will remarkably slow
to catch on to what was happening some
of them aren't very bright but most just
couldn't imagine anyone acting with that
level of cynicism and ruthlessness their
good faith made them vulnerable to their
opponents lies they were used in the
days after George Floyd died these same
trends accelerated dramatically it all
happened so fast that it seemed like
chaos at the time but it wasn't chaos
there was design just beneath the
surface consider the targets that the
mob chose law enforcement obviously but
not all law enforcement local police
departments must be eliminated they said
but the FBI is just fine and that was
telling then they claimed that
capitalism was the enemy but only
certain kinds of capitalism the mob
burned independent businesses to the
ground by the score they didn't say a
word about those businesses digital
competitors Google and Apple and Amazon
all of those companies were funding the
destruction then the mob told us that
traditional Christianity was racist they
desecrated churches in the name of
avenging slavery and yet and Tifa did
not touch a single mosque despite the
fact that historians say Muhammad owned
slaves as all this progress Democrats
continued their lectures about gun
control as they always do but they
ignored the rifles in the hands of their
own supporters in downtown Seattle the
real threat they told us was rural
Americans with their ar-15s we better
get the FBI on that arrest more farmers
in other words what looked like protests
were in fact highly effective attacks on
Donald Trump's voters his power base few
in Washington clearly appreciated this
at least on the right if they had they
would have told the country what was
really happening no this is not about
George Floyd it's not about police
brutality it's a power grab by violent
extremists but they didn't understand
that so weeks into the writing the so
the social media accounts of the White
House we're still producing ham-handed
posts about Juneteenth no one was
convinced by them no one was reassured
instead many voters were becoming
increasingly agitated by the lawlessness
they saw all around them whose
to protect us from this they wondered
the social media account did nothing to
answer that question we want to play for
you two pieces of tape that help
illustrate what life is like for many
Americans right now neither one of these
shows graphic violence we could easily
find tape the does show if there's an
awful lot of it out there but what we're
gonna play instead for you is in some
ways maybe more insidious than assault
what you hear is neglect and neglect is
itself a form of violence the first tape
is from a small town Fredericksburg
Virginia it's a 911 call recorded
earlier this month a woman called Tara
Durant
took her young daughter on errands
downtown as the two tried to drive home
a mob surrounded their vehicle and
blocked it from moving several people
jumped on Durant's car and screamed
obscenities at her child terrified Tara
Durant called 9-1-1 and here's the
response she got the area don't hit
anyone with your B I do not get out of
here
okay patient so all of the officers know
okay we can't do anything ma'am the city
told us that this is a sanction is that
you call it City Hall to let them know
about your frustration they're on my car
they're on my car ma'am comes the reply
we would suggest you call up City Hall
to let them know about your frustrations
those are verbatim quotes it's hard to
listen to that tape without feeling
emotional a woman and her child were
terrorized by a violent mob and then
they were intentionally abandoned by the
state that has promised to protect them
it was the ultimate betrayal of
citizenship you should know that the
mayor of Fredericksburg Virginia a woman
called Mary Katherine green law later
apologized but green law did not
apologize to Tara Durant or her young
daughter the mayor apologized to the mob
police had tried to disperse them while
they were rioting quote I am personally
sorry mayor green loss slobbered I want
to apologize to those who went through
this fearful experience again to be
crystal clear
mayor green law said that to the rioters
not to the citizens
she had cruelly abandoned all of that
happened in a little town of 25,000
people it's happening in so many
American towns right now here's what's
happening in our cities this is recent
video from New York you'll be forgiven
if you don't recognize it it looks like
a foreign country as you watch notice
how the police respond the squad car
just rolls on through the cops don't
even slow down they've been told not to
they don't try to enforce the law they
can't enforce the law keep in mind
decent people live in that neighborhood
decent people live in every American
neighborhood how would you feel if you
lived there you'd be very afraid you'd
feel like things were falling apart more
than anything else you would want
someone to restore order you'd want a
leader to take back your neighborhood
from armed children because armed
children are far more threatening than
even the worst rogue cop always but
local leaders are not doing that they
are not restoring order they're ignoring
the suffering of their people so what is
the White House doing about this well
the president announced two days ago
that anyone who topples a statue on
federal property will face 10 years in
prison
that is a welcome start what we're
living through right now despite what
people have told you is not a local
problem this is a national crisis the
riots are designed to produce a national
result the destruction of our system of
government and the removal of Donald
Trump people expect a president to
respond to a moment like this to fix it
and they have a right to expect that the
president runs the country if the riders
were Saudi nationals it would be very
clear that there is nothing local about
what we're watching we
understand immediately that it's
terrorism the president give a
prime-time address within hours the feds
would be hunting these people down and
arresting them if the writers were white
supremacists they'd already be in prison
facing life so the question is why isn't
the Justice Department responding like
this that's not clear some blame in the
White House counsel's office they say
it's dominated by Bush partisans who
were hostile to Trump we don't know if
that's true if it is true there's an
easy solution to it just ignore their
counsel send the lawyers to the basement
till November and have them reorganize
the card catalog or read Reader's Digest
from the 70s only a fool lets lawyers
make critical decisions anyway they're
not wise if they were they probably
wouldn't be lawyers
others say career bureaucrats at DOJ or
federal prosecutors in the States are
dragging their feet the Attorney General
Bill Barr says he is overseeing 500
separate investigations into riders good
for him
presumably one of them is into the
destruction of the Albert Pike statue in
Washington it took place last Friday it
was on live television so far no one has
been arrested for it he would change the
course of this country's future if the
Justice Department rounded up the
leaders of antifa
tomorrow along with every single person
caught on camera torching a building
destroying a monument defacing a church
and put them all in shackles and then
frog-marched them in front of cameras
like ms-13 and called them what they
actually are domestic terrorists not
protesters not civil rights activist not
CNN contributors but domestic terrorists
that would be their new government
approved title once they're charged it's
official in fact they are literally as a
factual matter accused terrorists and
that would change minds right away the
people destroying this country are
criminals few are brave enough to call
them that so naturally their popularity
grows everyone supports protesters this
is America we believe in protest but
watch what happens when you start
calling them what they really are most
people don't like terrorists terrorists
will never be popular even among
Democratic voters so charge them for the
crimes they've committed and call them
what they are right now the opposite is
happening the terrorists are more
popular than the President of the United
States and not just more popular than
Donald Trump personally but more popular
than the system he represents and
administers and it's obvious why our
system is weak it refuses to defend
itself mayor's let new countries sprout
in the middle of their cities our
leaders act like laws are irrelevant
everyone watches this happen it's a
potentially fatal problem weak
institutions die citizens develop
contempt for them and then they get
overthrown the same is true by the way
for heads of state when you refuse to
fight for the system you run you're done
spend an hour on Google and see if you
can find a single leader in the history
of the world who stayed in power after
failing to quell a rebellion
you can't the saddest part of all of
this is that our system is very much
worth saving it administers justice more
fairly than any system in the world if
we want to keep that system we have to
use that system and that means enforcing
America's laws with certainty enforcing
them right now at the moment of greatest
peril if we don't do it now we never
will do it ignore a law long enough and
it becomes unenforceable you'd be
shocked if you got pulled over for doing
58 in a 55 mile an hour zone
obviously and tifa's leaders would be
shocked if they were arrested for
destroying a statue of Abraham Lincoln
just a month ago destroying statues was
a felony now it's allowed
what will we allow a month from now what
will we allow by November the point is
things change fast and that includes
social standards they change very
quickly too just a few weeks ago
defunding the police sounded like a
crackpot idea now it's happening
millions of Americans support it many
Republican officeholders haven't thought
very deeply about why this is even now
you'll see them grin at the latest
insanity from the left can you believe
this they've gone too far this time
they'll say there's gonna be a backlash
really when exactly will that backlash
arrive because the opposite seems to be
happening what seemed awful the other
day is normal now it turns out that if
you don't bother to explain precisely
why certain ideas are bad if you don't
vigorous
defend your own worldview than you lose
bad ideas spread they quickly congeal
into conventional wisdom and then you're
done
this is especially true right now when
everything in American life is up for
grabs the lock downs shuffled the deck
completely four months ago you'd assumed
you were gonna spend the next 20 years
going into an office somewhere now
you're working from your couch you're
starting to consider maybe moving to
Bozeman and why wouldn't you and while
we're at it what else should we do
differently normal people are starting
to think like this once big things start
changing they tend to change more
quickly than we expect all of this means
this is precisely the time right now
tonight to defend the institutions that
we desperately need to keep in this
country those institutions include the
nuclear family our freedom of speech
small independent businesses absolute
colorblindness under the law the noble
tradition of nonviolent protest those
are the things that make us proud to be
Americans those are the things that make
America a place worth living in we need
to defend these things with everything
we have all of us must defend them
including the president that is his hope
of re-election for the rest of us it's
our only hope as a country